تواصلت الاشتباكات بين ما تعرف بقوه السور
الديمقراطيه
ومقاتلين من عشائر عربيه في ريفي دير
الزور الشرقي والغربي الشرقي سوريا وكانت
مصادر قد افادت بانها ما تعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه قصفت قاعده للجيش التركي الذي
رد بقصف مواقع تلك القوات بينما طالبت
انقره حلفائها بوقف دعم التنظيمات الكرديه
المسلحه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذاك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما دلاله دخول تركيا
على خط المواجهات بين العشائر العربيه وما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وبامكانيه
تطور الموقف التركي الى تدخل واسع في
المنطقه
وما امكانيه استجابه واشنطن لطلب انقره
بالكف عن دعم التنظيمات الكرديه وما
الحسابات التي تحكم علاقه الولايات
المتحده بهذه التنظيمات وتقاطع ذلك مع
علاقتها بتركيا
وكيف تنظر الاطراف الاقليميه والدوليه
المعنيه بسوريا كيف تنظر الى هذا القتال
في شرق وشمال شرق سوريا وما تاثيرات اعلان
دمشق دعمها العشائر في اطار هذا الصراع
[موسيقى]
بعد نحو اسبوعين من اندلاع مواجهه المسلحه
بين ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
ومقاتلين من عشائر عربيه في محافظات شرق
وشمال شرق سوريا تتضارب الانباء بشان
نتائج تلك الاشتباكات في ريفي دير الزور
الشرقي والغربي بيد ان القتال الذي اندلع
في السابع والعشرين من الشهر الماضي شهد
تطورات تضمنت قصف ما تعرف تعرف بقوات
سوريا الديمقراطيه قاعده للجيش التركي
الذي رد بدوره وفق مصادر كرديه بقصف مواقع
لتلك القوات
تطور اعربت معه انقره عن عملها في ان يوقف
من سمتهم حلفائها حلفائها واصدقائها دعمهم
لحزب العمال الكردستاني والمنظمات التابعه
له بحسب قولها
بينما نقل دمشق تاييدها العشائر العربيه
في اطار هذا الصراع
[موسيقى]
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من انقره
الدكتور احمد وصال مدير مركزي ارسام
لدراسه الشرق الاوسط
واستاذ العلاقات الدوليه بجامعه اسطنبول
وينضم الينا ايضا من واشنطن اندرو تابلر
مصار السابق للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى
سوريا والمدير السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس
الامن القومي الامريكي اهلا بكما في هذه
الحلقه وابدا معك دكتور احمد وصال في
انقره ما الذي يعنيه دخول تركيا على خط
هذا الصراع
مساء الخير اولا ان تركيا طبعا تريد ابعاد
التنظيم من كل تسمياتها وانواعها وحتى
حلفائها من حدود تركيا نتذكر انه اوباما
يعني تركت او سلمت شمال سوريا
وانصارهم يعني اتخذ او تبنى
كحليف لمحاربه داعش او ايضا ممكن نقول
كوكيل سيطره على شمال سوريا وشرق الفرات
واستخدم لكن تركيا اعترض على ذلك وعملت
اكثر من عمليه وطردت بعض القوات يعني على
الاقل من غرب الفرات لكن روسيا بامريكا
ووقفت مع قصه ما يسمى هوست ايضا
مشكله من يعني اداره كرديه لكن اضافوا بعض
القبائل العربيه الذي انتفض الان ضد هذا
التن
الارهابي تركيا تعتبره يعني امتداد من
باكيه لكن امريكا والغرب يقول هم ليسوا
لكن هناك يعني ادله كبيره ليشير انها يعني
هم نفس التنظيم ونفس الايديولوجيه ونفس
الفريق ايضا يعني جابوا الذي ازعاج
العربيه هو كوادر
كامل جاءوا من قندل ويسيطر على هذه
المنطقه وهذا يزعج الشعر العربيه وطبعا
هذا في مستجدات بعد حرب اوكرانيا يعني
امريكا اتخذت موقف اشد ضد ايران وحلفائهم
في المنطقه كان في نقاش ايضا او يعني في
حديث عن محاوله او خطه امريكيه لغرق
الحدود السوري العراقي السوريه العراقيه
وهذا طبعا يعني هذا
التوقيت ايضا ممكن يعني
يشير الى تحركات
السياسيه اقليميه يعني في
هذه النقطه الى الدكتور اندرو تابلور
التوقيت له مغزى برايك كما يقول الدكتور
احمد وصال وما الذي يعني استمرار هذا
الصراع الان يقترب من دخوله اكماله
الاسبوع الثاني اسبوعين
اعتقد ان هذا يظهر جليا امورا وهي ان هناك
مشكله لدى قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
الابقاء على سلطتهم في منطقه الفرات
وهم ايضا لديهم علاقه صعبه مع بعض العشائر
العربيه
وقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه هي منظمه
خاصه
ولديها نظامها الخاص بها
وهم ليسوا جزءا من التحالف ضد تنظيم
الدوله وكما اشار الدكتور اوي محقا فان
تركيا الان قلقه بشان علاقه قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
بحزب العمال الكردستاني
وهو يعتبر منظمه ارهابيه قامت بعمليات ضد
تركيا هذان الامراني مرتبطان تركيا تدعم
المعارضه داخل سوريا
وليس فقط القوات العشائريه على امتداد
النهر ولكن في المناطق التي فيها معارضه
تدعمها سوريا وتدعمها تركيا عفوا اذا في
هذه القضايا تجعل القتال ضد تنظيم الدوله
صعبا
وايضا جهود الحد من النفوذ الا يراني في
المنطقه ايضا يجعل ذلك هذا صعبا اشرت الى
القلق التركي هل هذا القلق التركي مشروع
في نظر واشنطن
اعتقد انه مشروع
في بعض الحالات
راينا ان حزب العمال الكردستاني استمر
بالقيام بعمليات ضد تركيا ان كانوا من
الاراضي السوريه ام لا هذا امر اخر ولكن
رغم هذا
بسبب هذه المشكله الطويله هذا يعني بان
العلاقه مع قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
وهذا يعني بان موقف تركيا متفهم
الولايات المتحده رغم هذا تنظر الى القضيه
من منظار مختلف هم يؤمنون بان قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هي القوه الوحيده التي هي
قادره على السيطره على تنظيم الدوله في
منطقه حوض الفرات اذا فهناك سؤال من سيملا
هذا الفراغ
ان كانت قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه غير قادره
على السيطره على هذه المناطق او ان تعقد
صفقات سياسيه مع العشائر
طيب هذا القلق دكتور احمد وصال
بعض الانبات تقول انه التطور الى قصف
مدفعي على الارض بينما يعرف بقوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه والجيش التركي هل يمكن ان
يتطور الامر الى التدخل عسكري عمليه
عسكريه تركيه واسعه في هذا النطاق
يعني تركيا لا تحتاج يعني
عمليه شامله لكن تركيا تضغط على دعم عدم
الدعم على حلفائها عدم الدعم هذا التنظيم
وبدون هذا الدعم يعني هذه يعني
هم يقولون سوريا الديمقراطي قوات
سموقراطيهم ليسوا سوريين ليسوا قوه ليسوا
ايضا ديمقراطيين وهذا يعني كل يعرف ذلك
الامريكان ايضا يعترف ذلك بدون دعم سينتهي
هذا هذا التنظيم وتركيا يعني تضغط على على
امريكا وروسيا خاصه امريكا واوروبيين وفي
الاخير ايضا يعني هناك مثلا من من يمنع
الفراغ لو يروح القصد يعني في مجلس
العسكري العشائري سوري دير الزور في رقه
في اماكن اخرى اللقباء العربيه هم اصل
يعني من اصل المنطقه وهم يملا هذا الفراغ
يعني وهم ايضا قادرين على
انفسهم ويعني قست هو دخيل من الخارج وايضا
يعني التطورات
نعم عشائر العربيه السوريه تمنع الفراغ
وهم ايضا قادرين ان يحكموا على انفسهم
ايضا كما تعلمون نظام الاسد يعني قمع
العشائر والسنه وكل الاطياف يعني لكن الان
عندهم استعداديه لحكم على انفسهم
لاداره شؤونهم في ايضا مثلا ليش ينزعج من
الممكن نتطرق الى انزعج منك هو يجند يجند
اولاد العشائر اجباريا ايضا هو يفرض تعليم
يعني شيوعي وايضا بعض الانحرافات
الاخلاقيه وايضا يعني
لا يعطي اي اي راي
للاهل المنطقه يعني هو يفرض نموذجه بدعم
دكتور احمد وصال قلت انه تركيا ليست بحاجه
الى القيام بعمليه عسكريه في اي ظروف متى
يمكن لتركيا ان تفكر فعليا في تدخل عسكري
او عمليه عسكريه واسعه في هذه الحاله
تركي عام عن عملت
العمليات سابقا والان يعني
واضح ان الوقت اثاني اثبت موقف التركي او
يعني قوه موقف التركي والان بالعشائر
اعتقد لو يعني بدعم بسيط او بدعم الكافي
هم يحكم
يقضي على على هذا القصد وتركيا لا تحتاج
ان تبادر او يعني
عمليات عمليات دقيقه عمليات دقيقه تركيه
تستمر يعني في العراق في سوريا لا تسمح
للبي كي ان تعمل اي خطوره على تركيا
عمليات الصغيره
لو اضطرت تركيا للتدخل عسكريه ماذا سيكون
موقف واشنطن
يعتمد الامر على نوعيه هذا التدخل
هل سيكون هذا التدخل
بشكل من الاشكال
فهناك قوات امريكيه
في المنطقه ولكن القوات الامريكيه ما زالت
شمال شرقي سوريا في تلك المنطقه وان كان
هناك تدخل على سبيل المثال
وهناك قوات امريكيه موجوده في هذا سوف
يدعو الى القلق ولكن اذا كان في مناطق
الغربيه اي في المناطق التي تحدثت عنها
تركيا
وانها استعدت السيطره عليها في عام ونصف
عام مضت فالقصه ستكون مختلفه وبالطبع
تركيا قد تقرر ان تستخدم القوات العسكريه
بطرقه مختلفه قد تستخدم المسيرات او القوه
الجويه
بدلا من ان يكون هناك تدخل بقوات ارضيه
اذا فاعتمد الامر على نوعيه العمليه
العسكريه التي تقرر ان قراء القيام بها
وانا متاكد بانه سيكون هناك الكثير من
الاهتمام من واشنطن
بان لا يكون هذا الامر حائلا ومانعا دون
الاستمرار في قتال تنظيم الدوله نعم
الدكتور احمد وصال لكن ما زال لدى تركيا
امل في ان يتوقف يعني
الحلفاؤها ان يتوقفوا عن دعم قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هل تركيا تعتقد انه واشنطن
يمكن ان تستجيب لطلب كهذا
اعتقد هذا ممكن بعد الانتخابات لانهم
كانوا ينتظرون نتائج الانتخابات الاخيره
وبعد فوز اردوغان لنرى تفاهم اكثر لتركيا
في ملفات مختلفه فهذا يعني قابل التنفيذ
اعتقد اليوم اكثر من السابق لان نتذكر
ايضا ترامب كان متعاطف او متفاهم مع تركيا
اكثر من بايدن وبايدن يعني بدا بشكل سلبي
لكن في الان مرونه وفي تفاهم ايضا لكن
ايضا نتذكر ان قصه يسيطر على نفط نفط
الشعب السوري شرق الفرات وايضا اراضي
الخصبه في نفس المنطقه والمياه يعني وهذا
ليس بحقهم يعني هذا حق الشعب السوري اولا
وشعب يعني اهل المنطقه دير الزور الرقه
والشرق الفرات كله يعني وهذا بدون هذا
الدعم يعني لا يستطيع ان يبقى قاسية
دكتور دكتور بدون هذا الدعم دكتور اندرو
بدون هذا الدعم يقول دكتور وصال لا يمكن
لهذه القوات ان تبقى على قيد الحياه هل
يمكن
لواشنطن ان يعني تتفهم وتقدر
انشغال تركيا قلقها من دعم دعم الغربي
والدعم الامريكي لهذه القوات لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وتستجيب ربما للطلب التركي
القوات الامريكيه ما زالت في سوريا الان
بسبب انهم مستمرون في القتال ضد تنظيم
الدوله هم لا يرون اي طرف يمكن ان يعمل في
منطقه ابو كمال
باستثنائي الولايات المتحده وقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لكي يقوموا بعملهم ضد تنظيم
الدوله
وهكذا
فهذا امر معروف الان ان انا لم اقابل ابدا
مسؤولا تركييا
يريد ان
يبقي منطقه ابو كمال خاليه من تنظيم
الدوله
تركت الولايات المتحده قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه لوحدها فهذا يعني بان قوه
الديمقراطيه سوف تتحالف مع نظام الاسد
هناك جدل وانا اتفق مع السيد
بان
القبائل يمكن ان تقوم بدور مستقل ولكن
هناك انواع مختلفه من هذه القبائل ولديه
القيادات مختلفه
ومن الصعب بالتالي ان يكون هناك توازن اما
ما هو جاري الان هو انه في شرقي سوريا راي
الاطراف هناك بعض الاستثناءات بالنسبه
لنظام الاسد والايرانيين هو نظره سلبيه
اذا فهذا امر بيننا ونعمل ان يتقينا
موحدين رغم الانقسامات الموجوده في هذا
التحالف الدكتور احمد وصال يعني واضح من
كلام الدكتور اندرو تابلر انه قوه سوريا
الديمقراطيه ما زالت فعاله وتعول عليها
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في محاربه
تنظيم الدوله الاسلاميه وذكر منطقه ابو
كمال هل تقدر انقره هذه الاعتبارات
الامريكيه في
ابقائها على الدعم لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه
يعني هذا طبعا احترم بقول استاذ اندرو لكن
يعني هذه التطورات اثبت اثبتت ان قست فاشل
وليس عنده اي سلطه بدون دعم الخارجي وايضا
هم يعني محاربه داعش ايضا انتهت داعش من
زمان هم اعلنوا ذلك لكن ايضا تحالف الدول
لمحاربه داعش يعني يتشك يعني يحتوي ستين
دوله يعني لو فشلوا 60 دوله يعني نتامل
يعني نصره من من قست لا هذا غير منطقي
تركيا نجحت ضد داعش ويعني هذا هذه زريعه
فقط
تنظيم الدوله
لا لا في في تنظيم ليس قادره ليس قادر ان
يشن اي شيء وايضا في يعني ضغط كبير عليهم
من تركيا من دول اخرى قست لا يعني لا يعني
اي اي محارب او اي قوه ضده داعش يعني هو
فقط يعني وكيل لمن يدعمه في المنطقه
يدفعنا الى السؤال عن يعني واشنطن لها
مصلحه مع هذا الطرف لها مصلحه ايضا مع هذا
الطرف هذا الطرف يساعدها على محاربه تنظيم
الدوله الاسلاميه وهذا الطرف ايضا وهو
تركيا لها مصالح ايضا كبيره مع تركيا يعني
فيما لو وضعت واشنطن امام يعني خيار او
لنقل الاختيار بين علاقتها مع قوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وعلاقتها مع التركيه تختار من
مصالحها مع من في الواقع
تركيا حليف للولايات المتحده في النيتو
وهي حليف طويل الامد وبالطبع هذه العلاقه
هي اساسيه وجوهريه بنسبه لقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه هذه ليست علاقه استراتيجيه
بين الولايات المتحده وقوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه وهي مرتبطه بقتال
تنظيم الدوله فقط
لعلكم تتذكرون في السابق الولايات المتحده
لم تنسحب من سوريا بل انها انسحبت الى
منطقه الشرق بعيدا عن الحدود التركيه
ولذلك تركيا تدخلت هناك وحصلت على ماربها
فيما يتعلق بتامين الحدود وسارت الامور
قدما الان يجب ان ننتظر ان كان تدخل اخر
سوف يحدث في هذه المنطقه او حرب فهذا سوف
يغير الموازين ولكن
تاكدوا ان واشنطن تراقب هذا الامر عن كثب
وخاصه فيما نقترب من الانتخابات عام 2024
لكن عندما تقول اندرو واشنطن تتحسب لتدخل
اخر هذا يدفعنا للسؤال عن تدخلات اقليميه
ربما هل تخشى تدخلا ايرانيا هل تخشى تدخلا
روسيا مثلا
في الحقيقه هذا سؤال وجيه جدا والان هناك
سجال بشانه الان ولكن اقول اعتقد
ان الروس والايرانيين ونظام الاسد وكلهم
عباره عن تحالف معا يريدون خروج الولايات
المتحده من شرقي سوريا
عسكريا ذلك لان هذا من شانه ان يسمح
لهجمات ضد مواقع الولايات المتحده وهم
يريدوننا خارج المنطقه وهذا لان العلاقات
بين روسيا والولايات المتحده قد تراجعت
مؤخرا والعلاقات بين روسيا وايران قد تقوت
بشكل كبير وبالطبع هناك ايضا مشاركه من
دول عربيه مع نظام الاسد والذي لم يؤدي
الى نتائج حقيقيه الى الان اذا كل هذه
الامور تجعل الحقبه القادمه لافته
للانتباه ويمكنني القول ان الناس قلقون
جدا الان
بشان الجهود التي تهدف الى دفع الولايات
المتحده خارج سوريا اعتقد ان ظلين يحدث
قبل
2024 ولكن في هذه الحقبه الامر ليس معروفا
ماله الدكتور احمد وصلت تشارك اندرو هذا
التوقع او هذه الخشيه ربما من تدخلات
اقليميه ماذا يمكن ان يكون رد فعل روسيا
ماذا يمكن ان يكون رد فعل ايران او ربما
دول اخرى
نعم ايران ايضا يحب هذه التطورات لانه يرى
ان حليف امريكي قست يعني يتضعف او يضعف
هذا طبعا مشكلتهم في نفس الوقت في
انتخابات يعني امريكيه رئاسيه هذا يؤثر
على نتيجه لان ترامب كان يتعاطف مع تركيا
يتفاهم معها اكثر وتركيا عملت اكثر من
عمليه عسكريه
في وقت ترامب ايضا يعني حرب اوكرانيا
ستؤثر على على المشهد في سوريا في ايضا
مثلا ليبيا والى اماكن اخرى لان في هذا
التفاهم امريكي روسي انتهى انتهى تقريبا
حول دعم القسط وهذا اعتقد
نعم هل يمكن ان يدفع انقره للتعاون مع
دمشق باتجاه دعم العشائر العربيه يعني
موقف ربما بين
يوحد الطرفين في هذا الاتجاه
لا اظن هو يعني يستطيع ان يعمل اي شيء
نظام الاسد لكن
القبائل العربيه او اشعه العربيه لو يدعم
مثل قصد يعني هم يهزموا قست في اسبوع يعني
ويخرجه من هذه الاراضي وهذا الدعم ايضا
موجود يعني تركيا تدعمه معنويا ممكن ماديا
حتى استراتيجيه ان في تعاون معهم وهذا
ايضا يعني ممكن يصب مصالح دول اخرى لكن في
الاخير يعني تركيا تدافع عن يعني حدودها
وامنها وفي نفس الوقت يعني هذا المشهد
ايضا يعني مؤقت ليس ليس بسيط في مصالح
غربيه روسيه ايرانيه صينيه حتى كل هذه هي
يعني يتشابك وتركيا في هذا المشهد يعني
تسعى لحفاظ امنها شكرا جزيلا لك الدكتور
احمد وصال مدير مركز ارسال لدراسه الشرق
الاوسط واس ود العلاقه الدوليه بجامعه
اسطنبول وشكرا ايضا لضيفنا من واشنطن
الدكتور اندرو تابلور المستشار السابق
للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص الى سوريا والمدير
السابق لقسم سوريا في مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي الى هنا ناتي الى ختام هذه
الحلقه من برنامج ما وراء الخبر لكم منا
اطيب المنى والى اللقاء
[موسيقى]